and today we will talk about how we use
Cassandra here together what problem are
we trying to solve by using Cassandra
and Cassandra and spark and we'll
discuss our spark and Cassandra
architecture oh and a little and a
little demo by the way I presented this
talk at the kiss under submit and that's
available online as well if you are if
you're interested in the slides they're
a few updates here but it's mostly the
same so who are we our motto is we power
personalized video experiences across
all screens if you watch a video on ESPN
comm Victoria's Secret REI
you've probably used our technology
without realizing it we found it about
six years ago
and ever since the beginning analytics
has been like pretty important to our
strategy we get over it as well over two
billion events a day from people
watching all kinds of videos on customer
websites so yeah some of our customers
we're fairly large Cassandra user we
have 12 clusters
you know from 3 notes to 107 notes but I
don't know 28 terabytes manage easily
over 2 billion cassandra column writes
per day
it powers like most of our analytics
infrastructure from the standard
slice-and-dice
aggregates that customers use to
discovery recommendations trend analysis
we run a range of cassandra versions
from 1.0 to one or two
and our largest cluster is one of the
biggest Cassandra installations around
so so what what problem are we trying to
solve what we're trying to go is so we
have mountains of raw data you know so
much like this over them so you don't
really know what to do with it
what kind of want to get to you know
feel Nuggets feel appeal gems right and
we want to do this quickly painlessly at
scale right I guess that's sort of the
answer to everyone's everyone's trying
to solve what we have today is that we
have pre computed aggregates we have
video metrics their computer launched
several dimensions such as geography
country city device type browser
platform their free order things like
that so this is fine so if if basically
I want to look up say I am ESPN and I
want to look up what are my top videos
in the US you know or what are my top
videos by device hi borders mobile or a
tablet whatever that that's very easy we
just pull out a key from Cassandra it's
pretty computer so this is nice
it's very fast the downside is that it's
very inflexible and it's it's very
difficult to change and most of the
aggregates and indexes are in fact not
read for example we store a sorted list
of say videos by city most people are
only interested in the top few cities
very few people are interested in the
tail end of things right and what if we
need more dynamic queries like when the
mix of several dimensions together top
content for mobile users in France I
want to do data mining a little bit more
interesting stuff when when I start to
move to the morgue
it's use cases then excuse me for a
minute okay sorry it's just have to wait
wait one minute eventually you'll find
it so so there we go
okay so in the more advanced use cases
then this model starts to start to break
down of this precomputing these
aggregates for example let's say you
have a hundred thousand cities and let's
say that you have one thousand browser
combinations just doing cross product of
two dimensions alone will get you like
you know a huge I mean you know
something that's like way way too big
right so basically imagine that there's
a continuum a scale between static
between pre-computation and dynamic
queries right so you can think of it as
on one end you can pre-compute
everything and and that's what your
customers who look up so this is nice
but it's inflexible on the other hand
you can do dynamic queries over your
data this might be like you know slow
but this is very flexible but might be
very slow and what we really want is to
kind of like have a a medium where you
can pre-compute your common queries you
can have flexible and fast dynamic
queries and uses easily generate a lot
of materialized views to suit your
different needs right so what that's
what you really want is something you
know kind of a medium now if we look at
some industry trends you have some new
technologies coming out for fast query
execution cloud era Impala drill is the
new coming project you got you probably
all heard about presto you have
in-memory databases you have a lot of
streaming and real-time
three marks that are coming out and even
for tradition a tube you're starting you
have things like cascading and peg that
allow you to write queries faster right
so maybe you know we can see if a
combination of these technologies or you
know something can help us solve our
pressing data problem right so I'm going
to talk about why we believe a spark and
shark is is the answer for for our for a
problem there's this a quick
introduction for those of you guys that
haven't heard of spark it is an
in-memory distributed computing
framework that doesn't mean that all the
data has to be in memory it does have
modes for spilling the disk and keeping
data on disk it was created by the UC
Berkeley ample lab three years ago and
it initially targeted problems that MRR
is traditionally bad at namely iterative
algorithms interactive data mining and
since then people have started using it
for a lot of general use cases I we just
came from the this just this week there
was a spark summit and the first ever
spark some it and it's pretty incredible
the number of applications that people
are doing with what spark is really
really incredible there are active
contributions from at least 15 companies
this is like insurance or the number is
probably increased so let's recap what
the Hadoop paradigm is so you have a
disc reader file system HDFS or any
number of replacement DFS's and when you
do have MapReduce face HDFS
you read data from HDFS and then you
after you shuffle the data you do a
video so you write the data back to HDFS
then you read it again now for simple
jobs and it might be ok like that the
more complex a job is the more stages
you have and so you find that your
reading writing from HDFS a lot and that
quickly become starts to dominate your
your i/o the smart paradigm is let's say
that I have two data sources and I the
first thing you notice is that you're
not limited to just map and reduce you
have some higher level operators such as
join so I can take these data sets
transform one join them together and
then this is where the magic happens
like I can cache the resulting data set
in memory from this point onward I can
then do transformations on the cache
data set very quickly because it's on
memory what we found is that in terms of
throughput memory really is king so we
did this experiment for in the first
case reading from Cassandra what the
cache being code just from a location
you haven't read in for a long time if
you are able to warm the cache
effectively this this is a dramatic
increase like maybe 8 X 10 X least so so
using your cache effectively helps you a
lot
Cassandra also has a lot of caching
options as you guys probably know
there's row cache and different kinds of
things but if I was to put this data in
inspark
in an in-memory data set that is another
you know one or two orders of magnitude
faster we found that developers with
lexpark one of our engineers looked at
it for 30 minutes was able to like get
up and running and write jobs right away
the collections API is very high very
high level so it allows you to think in
terms of high-level transformations and
you have three development three
languages for you to implement
SPARC jobs you have an interactive show
which allows for you know you can
basically play with your data and just
type you know let me let me map my data
and transform it in a certain way and
kind of get results out pretty quickly
for testing
and a little didn't see you know you
lead to quick development cycles and you
know these days oftentimes the the only
advantage that a lot of startups have is
or companies have this is basically
developer velocity you know so that's
something that we find very important so
on the right is our Hadoop a word count
example I did shrink it to a four point
font just to get it to fit on the left
is our spark word count example it's is
four lines I'll touch on the spark
ecosystem a little bit so what do we
have here so spark so spark is not just
a Hadoop replacement it has a bunch of
other bunch of other projects that build
on top of it
one is under underlying layer 2 the
project called tack yarn which is like
an in-memory caching for HDFS that
allows like very fast reads there is a
project called bago which is google
prego the graph algorithm on spark you
guys might have heard of shark this is
basically hi once mark finally there's
sparks streaming which is you can think
of it as micro patches so the patches
can be as small as like you know a
second or half a second and and that way
you can get real-time computation
fault-tolerant wait a minute sorry
so shark is 100% hike
QL compatible because it actually embeds
a hive but it is much faster however it
can actually we use all of your hive
sewage handlers sergey's and other
things like that I'll touch on this in a
minute
and if you're running the se you can
still use the SE and cassandra FS for
your meta store one one thing is that
shark has integration with spark so you
can for the things that SQL is not good
at expressing what you can do is you can
have a query in hive QL and then use
Scala and Java code to transform your
data in a way that is not possible with
what's 5qr so that's an alternative to
writing UDF's we'll talk about our new
architecture a little bit and how we
integrate Cassandra and spark and shark
so on the left's are what we call raw
events basically every time you watch a
video on one of our customers websites
like ESPN you have a little bit
JavaScript module or ActionScript module
which is sending data even when a video
you know displays and when you play or
you skip forward so sending events to
our servers so that's what I mean but
raw events from here we have an
ingestion pipeline that will write it to
Cassandra and what we call an events
tour from here we then use spark to
create various materialized views and
the way that we then utilize these
materialized views is that we can use
spark to do and you know quick pretty
fine queries or maybe we can run ad hoc
v ql queries in shark both both are
available
a little bit about how we actually
physically organize our clusters will
start with Cassandra on the notes on top
of Cassandra we put an input format and
sturdy I'll go into detail about why we
have it we basically wrote our own and
perform at and I'll go into detail just
in just a second about why we did that
and sitting on top of the input format
this spark worker that Cassandra if you
want to use like shark or hive then you
can on top of the improvement there's
something called a sturdy which
basically translates raw events into the
columns of a height or a shark table
coordinating all of the spark workers is
a spark master and we also have a rest
spark job server that we actually just
open sourced that makes it easy for you
to run jobs on spark so ours our schema
is kind of a it's mostly it's a
variation on a standard time series
basically you have an ID or a user and
you have events at various times we use
the time as as as the column key in fact
however we actually have a separate
column family called an attribute column
family the reason why we do this is
because there are there are a lot of
attributes such as a user's IP address
user agent things like that which repeat
in again again so we keep them in a
separate column family to one it saves a
huge amount of space and IO and to it
allows us to easily generate indexes and
to annotate attributes after the fact if
we want to
and so the way that we unpack you can
think of the job as like in Cassandra
you have you know rows and n columns in
a time series and now what we want to do
is we want to extract the you can think
of them as JSON blobs and expand this
into an SQL like table for you know data
warehousing so you can think of each
cell maps to one row this is actually
very similar to how cql reads out data
so your user ID which is essentially
part of the row key gets one column then
the different fields in a JSON would get
mapped down into their own columns and
so we just go from left to right and
then down to subsequent rows and we and
that way this gives this returns the
data in a format that you can usually
run for example a shark queries against
alright
this slide is by the way not in the
cassandra submit presentations different
options for integrating spark with
Cassandra versus that you can use the
Hadoop input format spark will use any
existing to be in perform at out of the
box so the choices are you have built
into Cassandra Collins family input
format this was really the only option
built an option before I think 1.2 I'm
not quite sure this reads this read
order rows one column family in more
recent versions there is now something
called a cql paging and perform at which
is pretty nice you can actually give it
a sequel query and we'll read out into
the relevant data for you and it pages
so that it will also handle wide rolls
pretty well as well as the supports
secondary indexes now you can also roll
your own I'll just back up to say has it
been format it let me see
so at the time that we did this
integration we hadn't looked into
Cassandra 1.2 yet so we then look at
securing it perform at so and the other
thing is that because of our layout we
have like multiple column families and
our indexes we we just wrote in perform
at now you can also read data from any
source in in spark without an input
format the big disadvantage is that
without a new perform ad you can't write
a standard Hadoop jobs like standard or
more jobs however it is actually much
easier to develop to read from Cassandra
without an in perform ad you can
essentially do it in one line that line
right here that says SC dot parallelized
what I'm doing is spark has a paralyzed
operator that will take any list let's
say I have a list of row keys a thousand
row keys and I want to read these rows
from Cassandra in the spark what
parallel lines does is a text at
thousand list element and distributed
across the cluster then what the flat
map does is it takes each row key and
then you something you can have
something that reads all the columns
from Roky and so you end up in one line
was something that can in its
distributed manner read in a whole bunch
of rows from Cassandra so if you don't
care about Hadoop compatibility or
rather MapReduce compatibility you can
actually save yourselves probably like I
don't know two weeks or a month or
whatever developing and perform at
there's also a JDBC RTD which so sorry
so RTD is a spark term that stands for
resilient distributed data set this is
sort of like the base base abstraction
in spark and it so it's it's basically a
data set that is stored in memory and
can be transformed there's also you can
also use the Cassandra JDBC driver with
the treaty support and do things that
way so there's actually a fair number of
options lastly there are companies that
are starting to open source some spark
and Cassandra integration so I just have
one make there that you might want to
check out if you do
develop your only perform at this couple
of tips to throw out you want to know
which target platforms you're developing
for if you've done Hadoop infrared
development you would or you just know
what in performance you know that there
are two hundred baby eyes there's a new
API and an old API plan is carefully
because they are incompatible but
similar enough to be very confusing and
some things that build on top of it
for example cascading I'm not sure if
it's so cascading well for example only
work or sorry uh hive up to until very
recent versions will only work with the
old Hadoop API you need to be fair to
spend time tuning your split computation
so I'll give you an example if you have
your only indexes in Cassandra that
could be a very long row you don't want
to spend a lot of time reading that one
row out and you're in perform at because
impre it has to do when you're computing
splits that's all done on one node and
it's not distributed you might want to
consider sorting row keys by by
cassandra token for data locality and if
you're using hive you can implement
predicates push down and your hive
storage handler which will let for
example I have a where clause you can
have an input format only read from rows
that contain a data you're interested in
there's a quick example of how we use it
for OLAP processing so out of the raw
events we use spark to create OLAP
aggregates and then we combine them and
run queries against different kinds of
queries let's see for in terms of
performance numbers so this is sort of
like the earlier graph I showed you for
reading from Cassandra with the code
cache takes
I don't know maybe two minutes to read
you know one half billion events
oops wait a minute when we read it again
and again the couch warms up and it
drops by a factor of three or four when
we process the data in memory then we
can get it out in like well under a
second so here's how we actually here
here's the workflow for spark and how we
do our processing first we start an
aggregation job in in spark through our
Java server this basically will read
data from Cassandra the raw of raw
events and process them and create some
aggregates the aggregates are stored as
a data set in memory distributed amongst
all the different spark worker notes
then what we can do is that we can run a
query job that taps into this data set
and return results and you kind of do
this again and again which keeps the
aggregated data warm in in memory and
allows you to run fast queries a quick
note about fault tolerance the cache
dataset lifts in the Java heap only what
happens if the process dies so spark has
something called lineage which is that
it remembers for every computation how
the the computation the exact
transformations that you ran so it's
designed to in the case of failure go
back and rerun your source commutation
so that you can end up with the same
aggregates now obviously this is rather
expensive you know you need to in the
case of Cassandra you need to read from
Cassandra again and do the aggregates
which might not be what you want
it turns out you can also replicate a
cache data set so you can replicate on
an order no to survive
single node failures that's another
strategy what we do is we simply
persists our aggregates or materialized
views back into Cassandra
and and then we just loaded into cache
this also enables us to to have multiple
sets of SPARC worker nodes that process
this data for hive ability and other
reasons so we'd like this approach it
also allows us to easily inspects our
materialized videos in Cassandra let me
see
there there's another option now that
sparks project tachyon will allow you to
cache basically it allows you to use it
as a write through cache to HDFS and if
you use take GFS or you can use
Cassandra paths for example then it will
cache your data in memory so that you
don't have to read it back again
essentially the data stored already in
memory okay I'll take this so okay it's
about storm versus spark so I would say
storm and spark are kind of like
designer address very different problems
storm is for streaming and you want to
stream from a never-ending data source
storm is very good for that did this I
guess we look at this a little
differently and that we are reading
terms of data so we think of this as
more like we think of this as more like
spark if you used to spark itself it's
we still have storm systems in
production so this doesn't replace storm
I would say that if you want to use
something like sparks dreaming that
might replace storm but I would say this
use of spark is more like replaces
Hadoop for enabling extremely fast batch
jobs
sure why don't we take this when we take
this offline so we can continue yeah
thanks
so I just wanted to show you guys a
quick quick demo of like spark and shark
or red or shark in progress this would
be part of just you watching a video of
me typing slowly so this is a local
shark node with you know one one node
creating a table from Cassandra using
our input format creating a cached shark
table in memory and running fast queries
so the first one is that we do a create
external table and we use our own
storage Handler and we use table
properties to set which casts under note
to connect to what are the start and end
times this kind of thing and in our
re-perform that understands based on
these parameters you know it can
translate that into row keys and count
families etc etc once you have created a
table that's that that actually doesn't
read the data right away that's just a
mapping now when I do create table
events cached that actually caches those
events in memory as a cache table and
that actually is what reads data from
Cassandra and now we want to query the
cache table for example I just want to
you know let's start with the really
simple I'm just going to select count
one from the cache table you know 1.4
million rows that you know the fast half
a second but but the real power comes
when you know let's do something a
little bit more complicated so I'm going
to try to get a count of a various you
know providers or videos and you get
like this long list again this is you
know extremely fast is a fast group by
operation and not but let's say that we
what we really want to do is we want to
get a top
okay or top-10 list of videos by count
and so we're gonna group we're gonna
order by the count descending limit 20
so this again returns like you know
they're pretty fast so this allows you
to do you know kind of queries that
would be pretty slow if you're done from
disk yeah and that's it thank you very
much we we are hiring so and I think
after this also we will have a we will
have a raffle let me see yeah thank you
very much